[Music]
hi
Filip here I'm a technical curriculum
developer here at Google and hi from me
Harish I'm a lab architect at Google on
this episode we'll be looking at Google
Cloud SDK a set of tools including
command-line tools like G cloud BQ and
gsutil to help manage your resources and
applications on Google cloud platform
will also take you through a quick demo
of a self-paced lab well will install
and initialize Cloud SDK and run
commands using G cloud one of many tools
that come packaged with cloud SDK and
the primary command-line interface to
Google cloud platform Google Cloud
console already provides you with a
powerful browser-based UI to manage the
GCP products and services that drive
your cloud apps with the cloud SDK you
can manipulate and develop against your
cloud resources using command line it
often provides access to more options
than the console but it also makes it
possible for you to script your actions
as well as login audit them you could
also use cloud SDK to access App Engine
compute engine cloud storage by query
and every other GCB product from the
command line and you have the choice to
run these tools interactively or through
automated scripts
BQ is another tool available in cloud
SDK for bigquery you can use BQ to
create and get information about
resources lists and update resources
load and query data use external data
sources export data and use the bigquery
data transfer service so that's a quick
taste of some of the key tools and
functionalities offered through cloud
SDK looking to install and initialize
cloud SDK on the operating system of
your choice click this link for info on
how to get started in this lab you'll
learn to install the cloud SDK
initialize it and run core G cloud
commands from the command line on a
virtual machine the cloud SDK RPM
packages are supported for Red Hat
Enterprise Linux 7 and cent OS 7 you can
check out the link to start the quick
lab here which will take about 30
minutes to complete so far in the lab we
have created a William with the Red Hat
image
we then SS etched to the William we
update the cloud SDK RPM packages
we initialize the SDK authenticating
when prompted
you
we can now list accounts whose
credentials are stolen the William we
can list the properties in our active
SDK configuration we can view
information on the active SDK
configuration we can view g-cloud
command help as well as specific help
for a command
so that brings our episode on cloud SDK
to a close we hope you enjoyed it we'd
love to hear how you've applied the
tools and functionalities of cloud SDK
so please leave a comment below we hope
you have been able to apply what you
have learned during the series using the
three hundred dollar free trial credit
when GCP if you haven't signed up for
the credit yet
check out this link all of our
additional training resources are linked
below
thanks again for watching and see you
soon